thank you very much Alex thank you the
rest of organizers thank you sponsors
thank you for making a strange look
possible
good morning everyone I'm here today to
talk about the bench AI can you hear me
well okay so when CI is an is an
organization
um that we have started two years ago so
it's an earlier status startup that
focus on bringing AI Technologies
machine learning software to the most
underserved communities in the world
before I go I enter into more details
about what we do use cases I wanted to
give some contest of why we assist
so first 40 of the countries has fewer
than
10 medical doctors per 10 000 people to
put more contest here European Union has
an average 50 dollars per 10 000 people
U.S 30 Nigeria has four
every day more than 800 women die for
chaos for reasons related to pregnancy
they are fully preventable all of those
happen in low-income countries
HIV is still the leading cause of death
for women interpreter reproductive age
worldwide and eight is now the second
most common cause of death among
adolescents globally and the First Coast
in Africa
so as most of you know probably know the
incidence of preventable mortality is
not a randomly distributed phenomena the
most significant Castle factor is
poverty and among them people of color
and children and overrepresented and in
this category women and girls
however despite of um I mean a lot of
problems has been a lot of improvements
in the last decades
so these improvements are for two main
reasons first because of the cheap easy
to use technologies that they have been
implemented for instance by sins okay
one shot done antibiotics one week of
treatment very cheap then contraceptives
or for instance
um oral tradutation therapy just water
power and you don't die of day rotation
the second block of improvements are
related with behavioral changes so for
instance boiling water okay they save
millions of lives and this is what we
are I mean what is our Focus this is
what is our thing behavioral changes so
we develop technology to promote
behavioral changes toward Better Health
outcomes
so this is uh this is our our vision
nudging patients and provided behaviors
towards Better Health outcomes we focus
on engagement engagement patients and
providers what does it mean
it means that by seeing some medication
is useless if people don't date them but
saying some medication is useless if
they are not in the self of the
pharmacists or of the clinics everywhere
in the world
so this is what is uh what is our focus
and before entering about what we are
developing I wanted to to say a bit
about where we are coming from a bit of
our story
so I say that our focus is engagement
patients and providers so indeed our
background is coming from the most
engageable Pros in the world video games
so since 2015 myself I'm part of the
leadership eventually we were working in
Japan and we built I think one of the
best machine learning platforms for
video games that predicts individual
player Behavior what they like what they
don't we we were thinking since then
about engagement so we were thinking
about what are the data that is
important how much time do we need since
a person to start playing a game to
determine which kind of profile of
player it is which kind of data we need
which kind of format
Etc
so and it was this this project started
in 2015 it was in 2017 that um people
from Apple they were the first to tell
us look I mean maybe we could apply this
to healthcare okay we were surprised we
were a very small team in Tokyo and we
continue with video games anyway and in
the middle of the pandemic one person of
that team moved to the Gates Foundation
and this is how everything has started
so now that we are in the in the Japan
section I want to explain a bit the name
so when she is a profession that doesn't
exist anymore it's a Japanese word it's
a Japanese role that was in the cinemas
when there were no there were no we were
silent films the only subtitles to
understand the film and most of the
people in Japan were not able to read
okay so the bench is were the ones who
were explaining to the audience what was
happening in the film so this is what we
want to think about ourselves we want to
explain what is hidden in the data
so when she is an organization that is
fully funded by the grace foundation and
our focus our mission
is understanding Behavior with data
Digital Data and intervening at the
scale data and intervening this is
something that I'm going to be repeating
all time data that's very important
because we are working in lower
middle-income countries and there is no
data in terms in terms of Healthcare in
terms of other many other areas there is
no data whatsoever okay so this is
something that this is very important
and intervening to find
be able to intervene to understand what
is working and what is old
our mission is at the end democratize
adaptive interventions
and how we are going to solve this
with mobile phones
Okay so
we are going volatas as you know mobile
technology mobile phones cell phones are
widely spread worldwide 80 of
penetration in Africa 50 smartphone 65
cell phone although it's growing
dramatically
and the in lower middle income countries
the use of mobile mobile Health
applications is widely spread
so much more interested in high income
countries why because it's much more
needed okay so at the end I mean this
this data generated by the users of
those apps has a lot of information that
so far is not analyzed it's not even
organized is a is just doesn't exist
okay so we can say in the status that it
is
and also the importance of cell phones
is that they are able to reach
everywhere okay so you want to scale
interventions is the best way to do it
for that we are building data Centric
Technologies
so what we are doing is um first
organized tracking and organize the data
that is relevant
second create a way that we can scale
and we can democratize this kind of
experimentation intervention engines
with all our partners in lower middle
income countries in global Health
something just to mention is that Global
health is a field that is not techy at
all okay so even conversations are very
complicated so part of our mission is
leverage the quality of the Technologies
of applications in this area of the
world and in this field
so we have development SDK to integrate
and to be able to maximize the quality
but also if it is needed either we redo
the app if the back end is very bad or
we do Pops from the scratch with the
data and the patient as a center in the
center
so our machine learning platform
consists in two main parts
data and intravenous I mentioned before
first tracking tracking the logs with
the right level and the right format and
second on Intervention and machine
learning platform that focus on all the
machine learning models that we have in
Productions are to inform and to do
better interventions
so what is inside this experimentation
engine that includes a clinical
randomized control trials a b testing
advantages pigmentation uh like
reinforcement learning base Bandits and
also three types of machine learning
models recommendation
censoring and forecasting sensory it's
time to an event to happen why because
it's useful for the interventions we are
not doing predictions just for the sake
of making prediction that is very nice
but we focus on the action we want to we
want to take
all right
also I wanted to talk about our vision
of machine learning platforms
sorry
so
that for us well I mean machine learning
platform is to focus on the problem that
we want to solve okay so and the problem
that we want to solve here is again
notch in behavior and for that we want
to include prediction of behavior and
prediction of the month okay so that's
the main core of our of our platform
and for that I mean the second most
important step first is a problem second
is the data that is the element that
we're going to use to solve that problem
so the data that we are going to track
and is important for us is every single
click that that the users perform an
interaction with the app okay we want to
see what they like what they don't okay
which kind of video Midwife in Ethiopia
is taking and what is the one never
takes or one Dropout we want to see for
instance if a nurse is using it for
include information then maybe some
pieces ever do and also the records that
they include okay if there are
Healthcare records results of tests or
maybe yes drugs that they they buy in
the pharmacy all this information is
what we store
and then all this information we put it
in a Time series manner okay the type of
format that we use always time series we
want to study behavioral changes okay so
it's important to see how every person
evolves uh in time so we do personalize
everything by person personalized by
content by patient if it's included in
the in the app information and then when
it's predicted for instance that either
a midwife is not going to pass a
certification in a learning app or
either a person a person that has
tuberculosis and has an app for
adherence to treatment is going to stop
to taking the the medication so then we
take an action to avoid this outcome or
to promote an outcome to happen Okay so
that is why we include predictions in
our in our platform
so as I said I mean all what uh what we
do is time series data or time varying
data at the end so it is not that we
have a problem of big data sets but of
course I mean it's high consuming
because can be long historical uh
Records so what we do is what everyone
does just split okay Partition by month
or depending on the on the type of art
that we are working with
so something very important that we
found out is not that this is relevant
for Global health I mean unique from
Global health or unique for lower middle
income countries is that the data sets I
mean people know that data is gold we
need to say track the data we need to
save it but what we have found most of
the times is something that is fully
useless okay so it's record that our
team or data scientists that are hard
data scientists put all the reference of
the world
but it's difficult to even distinguish
between users distinguish records you
don't know what is the truth is
basically useless so
so what we are doing with our SDK is uh
first and probably the most important uh
role we have in in this field is
organize those data
for that it is very this is also very
important we have created a unifying
data labeling for Behavioral model and
demand optimization okay so we have an
opinionated system of name
um name things and and with a with a
format that that we want so and this is
how it's created the opinionated SDK
okay where again the role of the SDK is
to track the logs and connect with the
with the app and be able to send
interventions and track again
interventions that already has the right
format to feed the machine learning
platform and visualize the impact
so this is the first step of our flow of
how we work
so
so we have I mean the Json files that's
through an SDK we start transforming the
the logs into time series okay so at the
end uh we have the metrics tables we
have individual individual level by
content so for instance even if it's a
drug it's it's alive okay suddenly the
the drug is not available anymore the
reaction of the user with the app is
going to be obviously different
so also we create what we call traits
that there are different snapshots of um
of information that is useful to create
the target population for this pyramids
okay something very important that we
have in mind to create this platform is
that there is no data scientist in this
field I never saw one okay so must be a
platform that is able to use for some
analysts or or people that is involved
in the organization of course we are
going to help them okay until they are
able to scale but it must be something
that is easy to use
also something very important about how
we that we are always repeating okay how
how we build our machine learning models
our engineering is that we and it has
been mentioned in yesterday as well in
the two Keynotes indeed is Simplicity
okay so we cannot have something that uh
that is even ourselves is difficult to
understand okay so we want to have
control of what we have and simplicities
with way of robustness and also we don't
want to
to solve problems that they never come
so or maybe I mean they are not here yet
we have enough problems okay so I mean
we love boring the stock is something
that we repeat a lot and
all that this is what we are reading is
to deliver AI to lower middle income
countries so I'm talking in a very
abstract way I want to go into a more
concrete samples
so for instance it has been very
difficult for us
to be able to to be able to focus what
is the priorities of the fields that we
we can have fastest impact so for
instance one is a primary care another
is woman women's health epidemiology and
Pharmacy these are the four focus of our
work
um we held Frontline health workers to
triage with from reinforcement learning
or to send recommendations of a
scheduling if someone would think that
needs a faster appointment and also
additional test recommendations
so we work a lot with midwives midwives
are the the last step in the chain of
the healthcare system in most of the
countries in the world women were
working with women sometimes that are
not even paid just for tips that mothers
give to them so there are many
organizations in the world that try to
improve the situation and many of them
try to improve their skills so there are
online learning apps okay that try to to
improve this we work with one of those
that is maternity Foundation
so with them what we do is to provide a
personalized learning Journey so here
for instance there's some data of them
so these are the corpse of um of
learning of some midwives in the y-axis
is the probability of stopping using the
app in the in the x-axis is the
different levels they have in the app so
we can see midwives that start with the
app learning and then drop out very
quickly others like this one I mean in
the middle and those that there is a
level that is very difficult for them
okay so we try to either send
interventions or try to modify the level
of difficulty but this was before it
wasn't it was impossible to even even
realize
so
another very important piece of our work
is epidemiology so we focus on
tuberculosis in adherent to treatment
HIV adherence to treatment and with with
the medication with prep also prevention
guidelines
so and malaria is is a very important
focus of our work so malaria can be
prevented diagnosed untreated but
however it will have cases and that a
lot I mean every every year so what what
we focus in this field is two
personalized incentives data mean to
frolic health workers or mainly
pharmacists to take malaria tests before
treatment because malaria is the most
under-treated and over diagnosed disease
in the world
and and the next step is a help
independent distribution and mainly
incentives with the right setup because
if you have the Bandit at home but you
don't put it correctly it's it's useless
also the amount of variability of the
skus of the drugs of the medicaments
that they are in the most of the
drugstokes of Pharmacy in the world is
extremely low
pharmacies are are very important for
our work pharmacies are core because
pharmacies are the the first point of
care with the Healthcare System of most
of the people in the world so you just
go to the pharmacy some places only have
the pharmacy and sometimes if they go
and they don't prescribe the right
medicament at that moment they don't
come back so they're they're extremely
crucial and and the amount of drugs that
they have is very limited
so they are very complex this is a very
complex problem okay so for instance in
Africa there is serial contability of
what is happening okay which drugs are
cell which uh I mean what is the demand
I mean zero okay so why is this is
because
um I mean not only Pharmacy 90 of the
retailing in Africa is done through
middlemen okay so there are many layers
and everyone has different kpis to
maximize so at the end first I mean the
products are extremely expensive and
second the demand is completely diluted
so this is what is uh what is called
Wool with effect so that what is the
demand of the of the of the town of the
city of the country and what the
manufacturer gets is fully I mean can be
completely different
so because of many reasons okay so more
and more they are developing emerging
this B2B e-commerce e-commerce startups
so basic basically it's an e-commerce
platform but B2B b2c will be very
complicated in this area of the world
and a part of the labor in a much faster
cheaper
there will be data okay and there will
be a connection with the pharmacist
and at the end also it could be with the
patient
so
a part of so we work a lot with those
B2B e-commerce platform that they are
emerging everywhere because this
happened for in many fields so we work
definitely with pharmacies on this we
also work with an organization in
Nigeria called life bank that use also
an e-commerce app to distribute blood
and oxygen among the clinics so one
daughter in the hospital just use the
app and ask for more blood
so we have them with the prediction of
the demand to assure that um
if there is going to be a lack of blood
they're going to start for instance a
campaign beforehand or if they need to
order beforehand also do it I mean
sending reminders
and also very important is what I was
saying you know like the data that we
can we will be able to to have about
what is happening okay so this is even
useful to to not be aware of Pharma or
big Pharma okay because so far I mean
it's not interesting for them okay so
there's rely on those middlemans and
whatever is fine okay so first I mean
what uh what we are working already with
one partner
is creating uh first helping them with
with the software and and the data of
the warehouse that they have
so be able to know I mean what is the
stock and what is not connecting this
with the app that the pharmacists have
every time that they order and also be
able to have technology to scan
prescriptions to scan tests that they
perform in the pharmacy a lot of Rapid
tests hypertension all kind of of
devices that at the end we are able to
even reach patients
this is a huge thing okay in terms of
data and I want to remind that lower
middle income countries are 80 of the
world
this is the product that we have and we
are building this in in Nigeria indeed I
was last week with them in in Lagos and
yeah I'm extremely excited because of of
the discoveries that that we can find
and how I mean it will be also a way to
implement interventions okay so many
organizations usaid Global fund wants to
to send interventions to tests of
malaria to governmental policy
interventions that would be a way to
implement them those incentives to
pharmacies and also a track of evaluate
the impact of those
so before I go to there's some
experiments that we have performed I
wanted to talk a bit about
other people that is also working in
this field or has influenced our work to
be honest there are not so many okay and
I repeat and despite that we are talking
about an area of the world that covers
80 percent
but I want to remark the work that that
Michael Kramer stereo Flo and her
husband manager did because it was
indeed very important uh for us so they
want an overpricing economics in 2019
for the use of random randomized control
trials in development economics so
basically is what they are doing is
bringing experimentation before doing
and deploy full interventions okay
um they're bringing evidence okay and
this is how any intervention that it has
um deployed no American countries
basically it was done just with the
intuition okay from the from the from
the lower North which can be completely
wrong and it was in many cases so the
fact that we think something to um
should work is not enough it needs to
work for the people who use them it's a
sentence that I like of Banerjee
and um at the end basically those guys
won the Nobel Prize that's for bringing
experimentation in this in this in this
area of the world okay so again so our
platform focus on Interventional and
experimentation
and I want to highlight how important is
experimentation so there's a sentence
object that way what is the truth is um
what is accepted upon adequate evidence
and if they ask a description of
evidence
um we need to refer to matters of
observation and experiment
another team I mean we thought I mean we
Implement in production deploy and
reinforcement learning I think one not
two three weeks ago and we thought they
were the first but indeed note okay in
global health so it is indeed the work
of million that we discovered indeed
recently and we are already
collaborating
um his team he's a professor in Harvard
and he's still
implemented in a call center in India so
a Restless Bandit that is just a
simplification that the simplest one of
the simplest ways of reinforcement
learning
algorithms basically an agent that is
able to learn on the Fly and give
different interventions to one another
and depending how you react and will be
able to learn so
so basically I mean that they did this
implementation to help women and
pregnant women in India and
they need to call them I mean they have
a limited number of people that in the
call center they have a lot of pregnancy
women in India so they need to choose to
whom to call to give them advice about
tests about uh follow-ups Etc so with
these algorithms they're able to be able
to triage at the end how to select
better
um the target population
and this is the the partner that we have
in Indonesia that that where we
Implement at this first time in Mobile
Health in in global Health in our middle
income countries and this type of
algorithms so this is again a B2B
e-commerce Hub okay so just to to try to
simplify the supply chain
and um there's I mean some data that we
discovered in the first um data that we
analyzed these are logs from from the
stock out okay during the pandemic and
here we can see how I mean the the type
of drugs that were in a stock out
processing that I mean obviously
correlates with the peak of um kobit in
in central Jakarta I think this is the
this is the data so we can see that the
main drugs the main drug that was out of
a stocking was respiratory antiviral
painkillers and vitamin supplements okay
with a proper prediction of the man
because indeed what's happened in other
areas of the world before that we will
try to have I mean at least have those
many things in a stock in the pharmacies
also something we're interested that we
found with this app okay that we have
observes also in others is that the
typical studies of Engagement that we
were doing with video games okay so this
is a plot where in the y-axis is the
connection time in the x-axis is the
in-app lifetime
so this means that the more you use the
app uh how I mean if you continue being
more engaged and engaged normally this
curve is a nest okay so there's a point
of saturation there's a point that you I
mean you don't use more of the app okay
or the game in the case if it will be so
it was very interesting for us to
discover that in this app I mean the
more they use it the more I mean the
time increases okay so basically what it
says it's an amazing Market fit it's a
product that people like to use and and
it's extremely useful
um
and this is the first pyramid that we
did with them so it was a test okay so
it was this summer so basically
um we just to some pharmacies for I mean
we did some some targeting based on
purchase frequency regularity and
basically we said okay we want the goal
was to increase the variety of the
product that that Pharmacy has okay so
we try to motivate them telling them
look I mean and imagine I mean it's a
personalized message right okay so if
you are in a more rural area so in
central Jakarta Farm a pharmacy of your
size always that purchase this product
that you purchase also order this one
one that you never did okay and what was
our surprise that it was the first
experiment and it was clearly
significant okay so purple means that is
significant and also even within the
interval confidence interval so
so what it means is that there is
appetite for optimizing information okay
so basically I mean in terms of
implementation of algorithm is I mean
many Commerce do I mean Amazon obviously
I mean so this is something that in high
income countries that
companies that they do okay but the
Revolutionary here is that is the field
itself okay and they use it okay so we
can use this in this type of
recommendations that sometimes are
useful okay in high income countries to
help them to be so I mean to have
visibility about information that is
very difficult for them to have
and this is experiment that we started
two three weeks ago about
um it's just a abundance in production
that is not still we don't see any
effect yet okay so but uh just to to say
the medicine that it was deployed
and one last um my last slice has
focused on on I wanted to talk a bit
about our team our culture so uh just to
mention that I mean this is the size of
the team so
people from many parts of the world I
mean Nigeria Uganda Lebanon us
Iran Pakistan and well this is very
important for us
um obviously okay so we are a data
science company so to reduce the bias in
data says and data sets and algorithms
the the most important thing of course
are the team that is analyzing those
data so it's not an urgent AI who is
building the models so if we are working
with women in Africa we need women from
Africa that analyze those data and
realize of the features that we need to
include that maybe other populations
wouldn't realize and just to mention
that well it's um the leadership is
majority women said our CTO and most of
the women in Tech I mean we have a bit
more of women in Tech and almost half
comes from lower middle income countries
so the type of roles that we have in our
organization are definitely software
Engineers we are building software so
data scientists of course product
designers and behavioral scientists is
very important at the beginning we
thought we didn't need behavioral
scientists because the partners are
going to know I mean which type of
interventions no okay so we need to
create a templates type of interventions
and and so on and the behavioral
scientists must come from the area of
the world that we are working
we are based in a beautiful Barcelona so
we have an office in Lagos a small one
in Nairobi and we are recruiting so we
also published some of our work when we
have time so we have about a couple of
Communications in kdd last year and this
and also in the ribs and hopefully we'll
have more accepted soon
and well that's all I mean follow us on
Twitter and thank you very much for your
attention
[Applause]
um sorry can you hear me yes yeah it's a
very nice talking inspiring work um I
just had a question you gave an example
with the food voucher that like as an
incentive to send to somebody to take
their vaccination or something like that
um so that seems an example for the
actual like patient or like person but
like then the examples you gave for
others were more in the healthcare
provider side so I'm just wondering from
the actual like end user perspective
people you're trying to incentivize to
take these things given that like most
of them have regular cell phones so you
don't really have a lot of data about
them like what is your vision to to
reach them or get to them so basically I
mean most of the Frontline head workers
they have okay so this is the part of
the population that they have a
smartphone the page the passion I mean
patient in most cases no but they can
receive sms okay so with our platform
okay we can reach um uh either with with
a push notification of course if they
have apps but also SMS is extremely
important and we work with apps that
work with Rolex at workers but also with
patient okay so in the case of a mother
that they include the symptoms of babies
and so on they can receive also notches
in order that or incentives to get the
vaccination of the babies even if it's
something that is physical we can say
okay
um
so you're talking about uh like trying
to help
doctors uh like uh you know to prescribe
stuff and uh work to ensure patient
compliance
but
like risks of
over prescription I mean I'm thinking
like how antibiotics are sort of burning
a bit of a Global Commons in terms of uh
helping uh bacteria evolve towards being
resistant
and like I'm also aware uh that in a lot
of places people just think of
antibiotics as sort of
um well health serum
um and so might want it or be incl
wanted prescribed or be inclined to
prescribe it even in cases where it's
not going to help does your app have
anything to prevent
um
to have antibiotics be used
only as they are helpful
so we don't do prescriptions we don't do
diagnosis okay the type of
recommendation we give are additional
tests or things of the like okay we
focus on the behavior to help from like
at workers we don't tell them prescribe
malaria or appeal or prescribe
antibiotics or do nothing okay so this
is something that we don't do it's like
okay try to find out more information if
maybe if we think that with the symptoms
maybe it can be a flu okay rather than
malaria or things like this what I
mentioned about prescriptions is in the
pharmacist okay so um with the with the
app be able to take pictures of the
prescription and have at least
accountability of what is the bias of
the hospitals in terms of the the what
is claim in the in the pharmacy because
there are two cases okay first is that
the patient goes to the pharmacy and
asks for something okay I'm not going to
live without the malaria peel and the
other is what the hospital is asking
also to understand the problem basically
hi there
um I was wondering so the most important
thing that we need to do when we're
helping people is to listen to their
needs
um is there a way that we could apply
these kind of techniques to gather that
information from folks like kind of meet
them where they are and gather their
needs and feed that into a platform to
inform like what development efforts we
even need to make
to be honest I don't think so okay so we
are not experts on that okay we always
go with Partners
um and it's complicated okay so far
traditionally has been surveys so we've
had very slow very slow the the title of
intervention is very slow and it's
um it's not working very well to be
honest and also extremely expensive so I
don't I don't I don't think so
thank you
foreign
's focus is on these behavioral nudges
um are you able to detect differences in
how effective these are compared to some
of the other barriers and access to
health care like infrastructure and
um some of those other things because
you mentioned this is you're working
with like 80 percent of the world so
you'll see a lot of variability are you
able to
use this data to see these other
obstacles more clearly
but I mean we don't work yet with 80 at
all
but I hope
um but
um
but yeah I mean definitely this affects
a lot okay so the contextual information
that we find I mean obviously for
instance a pharmacy in Central City in
rural areas changed completely also
changed for the profiles of the patient
of the or the front lack of workers but
they stage dramatically we also work
with health Navigators that try to find
out I mean try to facilitate to juicers
in in some countries in Africa to just
navigate into the healthcare system that
is extremely complicated and also we
find differences within the there are
differences between clinics and even
doctors okay so and yes I mean we try to
provide this information to address the
patient that tried to go to one place or
another
but yes a lot of that
thank you
hi this is a quick question about how
you're doing things at your organization
um one thing I know I've really
experienced it work with covid is just
like really struggling to get can you
get something yeah thank you one thing
that's been really hard with covet is
getting to know the people that I work
with and I'm curious to hear from you
running a like very international team
like what are some of the things that
you found worked for you in terms of
helping your team build connection with
each other
do you mean I mean Management in the
team or uh I was thinking primarily yeah
within your team like the employees
getting to know each other
um and maybe to some extent also your
employees getting to know the folks that
they're also serving
so okay to make it I mean something
useful is that we I mean part of the
leadership team okay we're working
together for many years okay so we had a
startup but at least this was helpful
um
we are I mean we're half an hybrid
system okay so we have people on site
both in Lagos and and in Barcelona this
helps okay with a startup starting from
zero okay
um being sitting together even in
pandemic we were with masks with uh
codes windows open we were hard and it
was very helpful okay so and also I mean
it was challenging because at the end
it's people coming from all around the
world and communication is challenging
communication between engineers and data
scientists I think is even more so I
think yeah communication is one of the
most important parts but basically
working sharing with chair it has been
helpful
thank you thank you
great great work
um uh question I didn't know whether or
not in your work you encountered
um
and part of the patients uh you know
suspicions and mistrust of the platform
or recommendations and
um if there are any things that you
are thinking about or had to do to kind
of relieve some of that I mean
personally I was surprised I mean my
home country
there's a lot of Suspicion about covet
vaccines and you know conspiracy
theories and all kinds of stuff that
you're like what but people really
believe them you know so which country
if I can ask Guyana
so so okay with our partners what we
find is that they are very busy and
sometimes they don't understand the
benefits that technology can bring okay
more than trust or not the type of
recommendations because at the end what
we are doing is experimentation okay so
they are going to see clearly if
something is working or is not
um in terms of of patients to to nudge
them for vaccination for instance I mean
now that the malaria vaccine is going to
be deployed and so on this is something
that we take into account
this is why behavioral scientists assist
okay so maybe we don't need to convince
them to take the the Basin maybe we need
to send device so basically what was
happening happened with covet okay in
most of the countries so intervene
basically so um but yeah
let's find out what works and what does
thank you
since
um it you're essentially building sort
of a medical history record of patients
um what is the consent model user
consent model for collecting and
building that sort of information and is
that collection only possible because
countries in Africa have less strict and
less comprehensive medical record
privacy laws
so well first I mean we are based in
Barcelona so we comply with gdpr okay so
second
um it is true in every different country
the norm are are completely different
completely completely I mean some of
those they they want us to run uh in
their servers in their country which I
mean we are not sure because of of
security reasons
um what we do at the end and we have a
very strong Partnerships team is to make
agreements with the government so for
instance in Kenya we are working to make
a dump of our results every day and okay
and put it in their service on this as
enough so we need to invest a lot in
research about the law and Partnerships
with key people our partners are very
helpful but at the end I mean all the
data is anonymized obviously because we
cannot have it again only because we
comply with the gdpr but we not only
comply with gdpr we comply with many
different things in every country that
we deploy
thank you
so the development world has a bit of a
history around looking at single effects
as like a Magic Bullet specifically
um Dr Kramer whose Nobel Prize work that
you mentioned his original study on
dewormers was eventually they went back
at the date looked at the data and
disproved that but at that point that
those values had already been extracted
to almost like I think 140 million kids
in India
um so how are you
um how do you kind of avoid one over
extrapolating across different
Geographic areas and also in the
original study that they found that some
of the effects with the dewormers had
more to do with how people were
interacting or how the people conducting
the study were interacting with the
students in the schools to improve
attendance as opposed to
um just looking at the actual like
medical
um
distribution of like the deworming
tablets so how are you differentiating
those kinds of different factors in the
ways that you're applying the
the data okay so something important is
that at the end I mean the work that I
mean this team I mean was doing is uh is
is lower okay so it takes years to at
the end analyze the data see the
conclusions I mean the cycles of of
deploys are extremely slow okay so I
mean we believe that uh I mean when we
at scale at that size okay so so we are
able to to see changes very fast as the
powerful the power of of digital data
working with mobile apps so of course I
mean if we if we have something that
works extremely well for our population
that we go to the personalized level
again okay so that's something that also
differentiated that something that we
can do thanks to to the technology but
um but if we see something that works
very well in Kenya and we want to deploy
in Rwanda okay okay their priority
information Library intervention that we
can do an experiment it can be the same
and see how how people react and who
react to this but but um but definitely
we are not going to assume anything and
this I mean this this type of Technology
allow us to to see faster and real
faster
thank you thank you
um so my question is this
um first thank you so much for what you
guys are doing and
um so like developing countries like
Nigeria for example uh there's a lot of
corruption and how are you handling this
corruption to be able to get
um the results you want
that's precisely for instance in the
type of B2B
um
um B2B e-commerce hubs that's what part
of what we are trying to jump to avoid
okay so directly the fact that um
that that the pharmacies are able to buy
to the distributors
we are we avoid many layers okay of also
corruption okay so that's one of the
things also with the data we will be
able to see all related with drugs that
they can pharmacists indeed sell that
there are I mean drugs that they are not
official drugs or or coming from another
I mean other countries that they're that
they don't have the stamp so all this
type of um of corruption also that
happens in the pharmacy will be able to
see okay obviously we will prefer that
countries government change from the
root okay but in the meantime this
happened there's this let's try to to
have better accountability and less
create systems that avoid or at least
reduce the way that I mean corruption is
established but yes we are aware of yeah
thank you thank you
okay I think that's all we have time for
thank you so much Africa